هنا في بلده بازار جك بولايه كهرمان مرعش
في فجر السادس من فبراير وتحديدا عند
الساعه الرابعه وسبعه عشره دقيقه اهتزت
الارض نتيجه زلزال هو الاقوى والاشد
تدميرا في تاريخ تركيا الحديث
هذه البلده كانت مركز الزلزال الاول الذي
بلغت شدته 7 درجات فاصله ثمانيه اعشار
الدرجه على مقياس ريختر وبعمق 16 كيلومترا
بال قفص كسرته
شعرنا بالخوف كثيرا بدانا نفكر في العالم
الاخر خرجنا من المنزل وشاهدت البناء الذي
امامي قد ينهار مكثنا في سياره جارنا لحين
طلوع الصباح
كنت مستيقظا عند حدوث الزلزال وكان ابن
مستيقظا ايضا وعندما حدثت هذه الهزات
المدهشه في قوتها اختبانا تحت الابواب
للاحتماء هذا ما تعلمناه من تعليمات
الوقايه من الزلزال وبعد انتهاء الهزه
الاولى خرجنا من المنزل الذي كاد ينهار
وشاهدت بناء مكونا من اربعه طوابق انهار
بالكامل خلال جوله سريعه في البلده لاحظنا
ان العديد من اصحاب المحل التجاريه اعادوا
افتتاح محالهم اضافه الى بعض العائلات
التي تحاول افراغ محتويات منازلها رغم
التحذيرات الحكوميه ايضا تتواصل عمليات
ازاله الانقاض من المباني المدمره من بلده
بازارجيك بولايه كهرمان مرعش زيدان زنجلو